bonjour et bienvenue dans le canton de
colmar a entre ville et campagne
le canton de colmar 1 s'étire des
quartiers saint paris europe schweitzer
florimont bel air saint joseph
mittelharth saint-léon jusqu au vignoble
de la commune dinners m
dans mon rôle de conseillère
départementale
je suis accompagné par yves m et d'âgés
et nous formons un binôme très
complémentaires
nous sommes à l'écouté de nos élus de
nos concitoyens dans tous les domaines
que ce soit sociale scolaire économique
touristique environnementale nous avons
un rôle de proximité être sur le terrain
et dialoguer c'est ainsi qu'on peut
définir notre mission
depuis plus d'un an nous tenons une
permanence tous les premiers mercredis
du mois dans les différents secteurs du
territoire à la rencontre des habitants
afin de répondre à leurs attentes à
leurs préoccupations
je me trouve ici au stade de la
mittelharth pour vous parler du sport
pour les jeunes
le conseil départemental encourage les
jeunes à la pratique du sport en
organisant des manifestations sportives
avec les clubs de haut niveau du
département à savoir le volley le basket
le hand et le foot c'est mercredi
sportif représente une belle occasion
pour les jeunes de côtoyer les sportifs
de haut niveau et éventuellement de
faire naître des passions
cette année c'est le collège molière qui
a accueilli les vides de la sppt volet
mulhouse et l'année dernière c'était le
collège pfeffel le conseil départemental
soutient également les clubs haut
rhinois pour l'encadrement des jeunes
licenciés et encourage fortement la
féminisation du sport un engagement
conséquent est aussi consacré à la
maintenance et au fonctionnement
des équipements sportifs je ne peux pas
parler du sport sans évoquer aussi la
qualité alimentaire dans les restaurants
scolaires
je me trouve ici devant le collège
lazare de schwendi d'ingersheim deux des
trois collèges du canton ont un service
de restauration pour les collégiens le
conseil départemental est conscient
qu'une alimentation équilibrée participe
au bien-être et à l' équilibre des
collégiens il encourage les filières
courtes et locales et valorise les
produits locaux et bio de saison
il sensibilise les chefs et les équipes
de cuisine à la lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire ainsi que les
jeunes par différents ateliers des
animations telles que manger bio manger
local c'est génial ou alors un fruit un
légume une saison sont proposés durant
toute l'année scolaire
restons à inières scène et
promenons-nous le long de la fecht la
gestion de ce cours d'eau est assurée
par le syndicat mixte de la fecht à bâle
à ce titre il réalise tout l'entretien
des berges
c'est à dire la coupe la plantation et
l'enlèvement d'embâcles il assure
également la gestion des ouvrages
hydrauliques tels que la digue qui se
trouvent le long du stade de foot ou
alors comme ici les chutes au niveau de
la passerelle le syndicat réalise
également une
une prévision en temps réel du débit du
cours d'eau afin d'anticiper les
éventuelles inondations ou alors le par
la sécheresse il investit également dans
les passes à bassins successifs afin de
permettre aux poissons
le franchissement des chutes pour
pouvoir remonter le cours de la rivière
7 passes qui se situe donc derrière moi
est équipé également d'un système de
comptage pour analyser la capacité de
franchissement d' ouvrage pour ce faire
au printemps dernier une pêche de
marquage a été réalisée est de permettre
d'identifier les poissons avec une puce
magnétique et une deuxième place sera
organisé ce printemps toujours avec
l'aide de la fédération de la pêche
il ne reste plus qu'à vous inviter pour
vous promenez vous balader le long de la
rivière